we talk about free speech a lot in the
show and you see a lot of people on
YouTube in the media and I get an auntie
FFA's knowing but kind of funny you look
at Facebook throttling news that's all a
problem but this is an example of where
freedom of speech is actually a line in
the sand that can mean the difference
between life and death and how that ties
in to the way that we consume
information right now is is is chilling
when you follow the timeline to the
story so recently a Pakistani man was
sentenced to death for blasphemy on
Facebook the Guardian writes an
anti-terrorism court in Pakistan has
sentenced a man to death for allegedly
committing blasphemy on Facebook the
latest step in an intensified crackdown
on dissent on social media so let me
preface this what are blasphemy laws in
Pakistan we need to know what it is that
we're talking about before we get to the
time frame here basically anything
derogatory of the Islam or Quran of
course any depictions of Muhammad
best-case scenario you get three years
in prison we can even see here we've
we've covered this on the website a lot
we're by mob rule people get killed
sometimes even women in kids because of
blaspheming are because of pictures of
Mohammed we've seen terrorist acts
committed so you can really get three
years in prison you can get torn apart
by a mob or in this case actual
sentencing to death as issued by the
state this is important because this is
who Facebook themselves and Zuckerberg
are linking arms with Pakistan is number
four now it fourth in the world as far
as countries on the terror watchlist
countries that produce terrorism this is
important because we read this story and
immediately I had a flashback to
something we wrote about a couple months
ago on our website where Pakistan asked
Facebook to fight blasphemy and Facebook
sent a team to Pakistan to help
investigate who's written here not only
our site but the BBC Facebook agreed to
send a team to Pakistan to address
reservations about content on the social
media site according to their interior
ministry so this is why this matters
Facebook has real power and influence
this is effectively a soft institution
of Sharia law on a social media platform
when you think about it this is a way
Pakistan came to us said hey we need
help with dealing with blasphemy Mark
Zuckerberg in wanting to appeal to the
underdog wanting to appeal to
the most politically correct voice to
appease at the time no moral compass
said sure we'll help you with blasphemy
laws fast what they send a team to help
them investigate fast forward two months
and a man is being sentenced to death
simply for speaking out against the
Prophet on Zuckerberg platform is there
a couple over here is Facebook
potentially an accessory to murder and I
say that without a hint of hyperbole I
think it's a conversation that that
needs to be had and this is why this
matters Facebook has it has aligned
themselves repeatedly with countries
with voices that line up against freedom
they constantly want to strip you of
your rights that constantly want to
remove freedom of speech which
ironically was supposed to be the
purpose of purpose of social media and
the platform if you look at Mark
Zuckerberg used to say this story in and
of itself may not seem so bad but when
you look at the priorities that Facebook
has gone out of their way to express so
Facebook has not come out and said you
know what no more working with Pakistan
that we're done we're done I cannot
believe that you did this to us we sent
but this is not what we wanted this is
not what we meant no as a matter of fact
during that same time Facebook has been
removing ex-muslims pages
they've been removing our Quran
challenge videos they've been removing
posts that have pictures of Muhammad on
them so that is something to take into
context but what does Facebook really
care about well Zuckerberg wants to
fight Isis with love these are views
that they express either views they go
out of their way for the press junkets
they want to censor anti-migrant
rhetoric in germany they'll go out of
their way to fight that they want to
crack down on fake news like louder was
crowder that was a story member Gizmodo
they talked about them throttling us
they've tried to fact-check us when we
talked about the pamphlets teaching
people not to rape being passed out in
Cologne Germany and they're there
fact-checking was well these these
pamphlets weren't specifically printed
for Cologne Germany they were passed out
and yeah there was a lot of rape there
was booze there were stories a
significant amount of rape but these
pamphlets were these were just these
reprinting this was their argument so
when you take that and you see the
priorities from Facebook and you see it
from YouTube you see it from Twitter you
see it from these activists these
political activists who have no moral
compass have so much money they feel so
much guilt and they automatically want
to assume some kind of moral high ground
with an underdog and right
now it's Islam they are in trying to be
tolerant sitting at the altar of evil
who will tolerate nothing from Western
society you see with Sharia law you
don't think for a second if Pakistan had
this ability to bring that kind of
punishment to the States
that they would yours truly guess who
can't take his passport to Pakistan any
time soon it amazes me that Facebook
will go out of their way to talk about
to talk about
we need a treat Isis would love to talk
about tolerance - to have a meeting with
Glenn Beck and say listen we need to
include more voices and then they agree
to send someone to Pakistan at a request
to deal with blasphemy and they tell
Merkel they're gonna shut down
anti-muslim voices and then someone is
is sentenced to death this man is going
to die this man is going to die for
using a platform that Mark Zuckerberg
created and then use to subvert
alongside the Pakistani government to
find this guy and sentence him to death
I don't know how someone like that
sleeps at night and when you get rid of
the whole okay left versus right let's
have a civil dialogue absolutely Mark
Zuckerberg and these people in Silicon
Valley these social media giants who are
being guided by situational ethics and
have no sense as to what the enemy wants
to do to them or the Western world right
now Mark Zuckerberg and the rest of you
you quite literally will have blood on
your hands this man was killed because
of who you tried to appease because of
the people you tried to help so when we
say freedom of speech is absolute and
you want to get into the nuance the
reason we do it is so that [ __ ] like
this doesn't happen if freedom of speech
is absolute the second Pakistan comes in
there and says hey can you help us deal
with blasphemy you know you say no like
this video subscribe by clicking the
button it's a circular button now that
says subscribe if not head on over the
young turks that's probably more your
speed although they're coming over here
[ __ ] we know you're here watching i can
smell you from here there's also
recommended video box playing right up
there you can join the hmong club a lot
of its credit.com slash mug club for
daily content so we're not dependent
here on youtube shank go no go you don't
need to stay here this isn't good for
it's bad for your soul